when i watched all those clips cut up in
fact when i first started talking about
manosphere stuff
i said you know give me some content i
want to see what people are saying and
they sent me a whole bunch of stuff
about andrew tate and it was like these
little cut up things and i was like well
he's crazy what is he saying about what
is that what is you know i found myself
going down that path right then i watch
all these long-form videos and i'm like
well wait a minute i've just been played
and i think part of life and being an
adult is acknowledging those moments i
got played in the beginning of covid too
i admitted it i came out i said i was
wrong i was that idiot wiping down my
packages from the grocery store but you
have to acknowledge that stuff to to to
grow as a person and actually turn into
a full-formed adult
so here i am saying again
i bought into this this guy's always
talking about women he's always hating
on women it's all about gender turns out
it's not it's a very small part of what
he's saying and oftentimes he's very
critical of men as well so this
particular part of the video um tyler on
gender i think is significant it's at
105. i just want to play this and then
rollo get your reaction to someone who's
watched a lot of his content and can
speak a little bit more to this point
i'm massively anti-drugs but when i do
videos saying to men avoid men who take
drugs
avoid men who are disloyal
nobody comments on it but if i say avoid
having a girlfriend who takes drugs
avoid having a girlfriend who's disloyal
people call me a misogynist
it's not about gender i'm just trying to
teach people to stay away from low
quality toxic people and just try and
elevate themselves and create their
reality to be around high quality people
and positive people male or female
there's no gender associated it's only
the fact that the media
these people chopping my videos up
whoever they are
taking out context and only focusing on
the times women were mentioned which is
a very small percentage two or three
percent of my overall content and
ignoring all the time i said the exact
same thing about men or the times i
loved women okay rolo your reaction
ah um i
he's he's uh he's describing something
like i've dealt with for quite some time
now which is if you try to help someone
get off of drugs or like if you help
your friend like stop smoking right if
you stop if you say hey dude heroin is
bad for you stop doing heroin let's go
to the rehab i'm going to help you out
doing stuff like that
people will call you a superhero right
it doesn't matter male female whatever
but if you go and you tell that guy look
dude i don't think you should be with
this girl because she's kind of toxic
she's a toxic element in your in your in
your life and i don't want to see you
ruin your life with this woman i don't
want to see you get married to this
person because this is really a bad
situation if i step in and do that then
i'm a busy body then i'm then i'm like
cr you know i'm like well if they're
happy then who cares right if they're in
love love is love right that's to come
in and to talk i can save you from
heroin but i can't save you from a bad
relationship or from what i see that's
happening right and it's exactly what
he's saying right here the idea
that you can say one thing about men you
could say one thing about women it's uh
there's actually a psychological
sociological uh phenomenon that has been
well studied since the early 90s and
it's called the women are wonderful
like phenomenon right i'm dead serious
that's what they called it back in like
91 or 93 something like that and it's
very well studied so anything that is
flattering to women is automatically
seen as something that is more
legitimate whether it's research or
whatever is more legitimate than
anything that is sort of presents an
unflattering light of women and it's
very well known in psycho and
psychological circuit go look it up it
says the win women are well you can find
it on wikipedia it's the women are
wonderful phenomenon or dynamic and what
what it basically boils down to is again
the separate standard of justice between
men and we have a higher criteria we
have a higher um standard of say like
men have a burden of performance that
women do not have just simply because
they are women they're we get we afford
women a default respect just because
they're women not because they've done
something that's respectable that's a
male form of respect when we look at
women we go well you don't respect women
andrew j doesn't respect women if you go
and you say it exactly like you're
saying before you say exactly the same
thing you say stay away from guys who
are on drugs stay away from women who
are on drugs right that's not just logic
right that's just like rational
reasonable logic but for men we go yeah
because those guys
who are taking drudge drugs there's
something wrong with them and they they
could be like
that that's the wrong element but if
it's a woman then we go oh well maybe
she needs help or don't judge a book by
a cub by its cover it's also this
non-judgmentalism that comes along with
emotionalism you probably will hear this
and damn near any new like netflix
series or any new uh anything that has
like any new popular media it's always
don't judge me but and then i'm going to
go into something that you should judge
before
um
it's this non-judgmentalism it's like
almost like it's part of this this
religion of the woke really which we're
not supposed to judge people for
anything whatsoever unless a guy then we
can judge that dude but if it's a woman
it's like don't judge me for what i'm
about to do not non-judgmentalism and
i've always promoted this as like we
need to be more judgmental we need to be
more discerning we need to look at that
and go you know what if we're going to
apply a a rational logical you know
basis for what makes someone respectable
or makes somebody you know toxic we need
to be able to balance that between both
sexes but you're never going to do that
because we see women as the vulnerable
sex we see them as the oppressed sex we
see them as you men have an innate
protector you know provider instinct for
women and so therefore any guy that is
that says something like don't don't
give you know be around women who are on
drugs
that's that's a prompt for even guys to
go well leave her alone mister you know
you leave her alone you know because the
guy wants to step up and protect this
poor woman even though she's on drugs
it's okay because he's gonna step in and
be her savior kind of thing that happens
for women it does not happen for men
yeah so men have that burden of
performance and they have that burden of
respectability that women do not have
i've covered it on here even in terms of
criticism and saying you know you i see
women call guys fat ugly bald short they
can say it all but if you turn around
and you call a woman on the cover of a
magazine who is noticeably obese and you
say that's not healthy well good luck to
you man good luck to you you're done you
know and i do it here because i feel
like it's there are people that need to
be judged there are people who need to
be judged and there this this idea of
not judging people actually has seeped
so far into loonyville we played a video
the other day
of a woman who was
saying that it was too mean to call a
pedophile a pedophile so we needed to
create a new terminology for a pedophile
because you would make the pedophile
feel bad and my words were judge away on
these people i mean this is ridiculous
what's going on so it's not just seeping
this woke culture and this refusal to
recognize fact versus fiction and this
refusal to hold people accountable for
bad behavior and be willing to judge i
don't care if it's male female i don't
care bad behavior is bad behavior i
don't care and also you don't need to
you know always need a blankie every
time someone makes a judgment on you but
just to close that point it's it's
dangerous to society at large to have
this new caliber of certain people are
protected from judgement and other
people you can throw arrows at them all
day long that's not the markings of a
healthy society go ahead
have you ever heard that song before he
cheats by carrie underwood
yes
where she's talking about like you know
vandalizing this guy's big beautiful
four-wheel drive car yeah screaming a
key in it and like taking a baseball bat
to it and you hear this come up in the
club or something and every woman in the
club
has those lyrics committed memorize
those lyrics and probably still to this
day because a while back they could
probably still to this day recite those
lyrics because it's this anthem and it's
it's
like build up in this field feel good
kind of thing if it you reverse the
roles that guy goes to jail
if you do
if the wife cheats or the girlfriend
cheats and you go and you vandalize her
car guess what
you ain't singing songs about that it's
not a top 40 song anymore that's the
difference
if you like the short clip you can catch
another one here or you can catch the
full episode right here
[Music]